há 15 anos eu vivia o auge da minha
carreira eu tinha fundado uma das
primeiras agências digitais do brasil
numa época onde internet exigia apenas
dentro da universidade
não tinha nem acesso eu tinha vendido a
agência para a maior rede de propaganda
mundial e cuidava da operação deles na
internet na américa latina
eu viajava um monte conheci pessoas
incríveis e me sentia criando o futuro e
aquilo me movia
até que um dia eu e meu marido tivemos a
notícia que mudaria as nossas vidas
eu tinha acabado de saber que estava
grávida da nossa primeira filha e ele
foi diagnosticado com um câncer
agressivo e os médicos diziam que ele
teria pouco tempo de vida
foram meses de exames e consultas e
todos diziam a mesma coisa
até que um dia nós descobrimos que o
diagnóstico estava errado
ele não tinha câncer só que naquele
momento a mudança dentro de nós já tinha
acontecido naquele momento eu parei de
viver o futuro para viver o presente eo
presente pra nós
tinha um nome veleiro santa paz
lucas tinha um sonho de infância demorar
a bordo de um veleiro e quando nós
achamos que ele não teria mais amanhã
nós largamos nossos trabalhos
compramos esse celeiro e fomos morar a
bordo com a nossa filha de 1 ano e 1 mês
esse mesmo em setembro faz 13 anos que
nós começamos a navegar e desses anos
seis nós moramos a bordo foram mais de 2
mil dias e noites vendo a linha do
horizonte
e graças a deus nós tivemos muito mais
horizontes do que os médicos achavam e é
difícil
dizer o impacto que esses anos tiveram
em mim e que vão ter as nossas filhas
nós agregamos mais de 30 países
eu atravessei o atlético grávida da
nossa segunda filha
nós mudamos para paraty uma cidade na
costa do rio de janeiro
nós voltamos a navegar e chegamos a nova
zelândia onde nós moramos há três anos
quando eu olho a minha vida ao longo do
tempo
eu percebo que a forma como nós olhamos
o mundo abre novas perspectivas
dependendo do jeito que a gente veja o
mundo ao nosso redor
as possibilidades existem ou não é sobre
isso que eu quero falar com vocês hoje
sobre como eu passei a enxergar o mundo
de uma maneira que abre possibilidades
mesmo quando os obstáculos fazem com que
a gente acredite que isso não seja
possível e esse olhar pra mim começou
com o mar o mar está na minha vida desde
muito pequena quando eu era pequena
mergulhava e ao afundar
parecia que o tempo parava naquela época
eu não sabia mas uma é a minha meditação
então agora eu queria pedir para vocês
uma coisa por favor fechem os olhos que
eu vou levar vocês para o mar comigo
ouçam o barulho das ondas
não pensei em mais nada
vocês estão o fim do oceano pacífico
imaginem que entre vocês e horizonte não
tem nada e na céu e mar
olhar além do horizonte abre novas
possibilidades
e possibilidades vocês
qual é o seu lugar favorito
que sentimento ele traz
agora abra os olhos
essa foi uma das coisas que aprendi
encontra em um lugar que te acalma e
medite ali e meditar é uma coisa
interessante porque todo mundo fala de
meditação eu não acreditava
você imagina o que foi para o executivo
de internet acalmar
naquela época na agência e chamavam de
em sandro e sida
pois é e omar me mostrou que isso é
possível e me mostrou que meditar não
precisa simplesmente ser fica parado o
assentado o que hoje eu faço mas que
vocês também podem achar forma de vocês
mas para desenvolver esse olhar a calma
minha mente foi essencial
e vocês imaginam que é navegar metade do
mundo
a menos de 10 quilômetros por hora
eu tinha que desacelerar e eu digo
desacelerem porque isso é importante
eu achava que a forma mais rápida de
fazer uma coisa para fazer essa coisa
sem parar e eu descobri que a forma mais
rápida e melhor de fazer uma coisa às
vezes é dar uma pausa é silenciar e
voltar quando a gente está pronto e eu
vi uma frase esses dias que foi
exatamente isso que eu vivo é de
martinho lutero ele diz
hoje eu tenho tanta coisa para fazer que
eu vou ter que rezar três horas para dar
conta de tudo
pode parecer um pouco diferente mas é um
pouco de como eu vejo hoje e como eu
faço as coisas e eu queria dizer que
essa minha história com o mar
ela começou com o meu pai e meu pai é
uma pessoa que me ensinou muito sobre
superação de limites
quando eu nasci meu pai tinha acabado de
perder um filho de 19 anos
ele tinha perdido a sua primeira esposa
também de câncer tinha falido uma
empresa e ele era e é até hoje de longe
a pessoa mais otimista que eu já vi na
minha vida
há dois anos meu pai teve uma perna
amputada e ele anda dirige e faz tudo
sozinho com 92 anos e ele está aqui hoje
o meu pai me ensinou a superar limites e
enxergar os obstáculos como
possibilidade de crescimento
eu queria perguntar pra vocês e que
vocês admiram nas pessoas que vocês mais
amam que pessoas vêm pra vocês o que ela
se inspiram
pra mim foi muito importante entender o
que eu aprendo com essas pessoas
eu venho de uma família de
empreendedores e eu me tornei uma
empreendedora e tudo na minha vida eu
aprendi fazendo eu aprendi a navegar
morando a bordo eu aprendi o que é a
internet fazendo uma agência mas isso
não quer dizer que eu não me prepare
para as coisas
eu me preparo apenas o suficiente para
ter coragem de dar o salto
depois a gente morar a bordo por dois
anos
eu engravidei de novo e nós resolvemos
voltar para o brasil
eu atravessei o atlântico grávida de
cinco meses e nós fomos morar em paraty
assim que nós chegamos nós percebemos
que a educação ali era muito precário
as poucas escolas que existiam não
falava com os nossos valores
então uma educadora sensacional que nós
conhecemos a teresita sugeriu
por que vocês não fazem uma escola e
aqui não me parecia impossível como
assim fazer uma escola não entendo nada
de educação foi calma calma não precisa
pensar na escola
vocês conhecem outras pessoas que pensam
como vocês se sentem vários pais que
também são frustrados e vocês poderiam
fazer uma rede de paz claro fazer uma
rede de paz é fácil
em uma semana nós tínhamos um grupo de
pais reunidos na nossa casa para
conversar sobre o tipo de educação que
nós queremos para os nossos filhos
em menos de dois meses nós tínhamos
fundado uma escola waldorf baseada no
desenvolvimento humano e ainda por cima
comunitária onde metade dos alunos
os pagam metade não pagam essa escola
hoje tem 10 anos e ela tem de mais de
100 famílias
e aí eu descobrir que parecia impossível
pra mim mas que podia ser improvável mas
não é impossível
e hoje eu olho mundo muito dessa forma
coisas difíceis podem ser improváveis
mas elas não são impossíveis e eu queria
contar pra vocês uma história que nós
voltamos para o mar depois de paraty
depois de quatro anos cuidando dessa
escola
mas dessa vez foi diferente eu comecei a
olhar outros contornos na linha do
horizonte
eu comecei a ver mais longe e um dia nós
subimos essa montanha em uma o pt um
ator da polinésia francesa e essa vista
me marcou profundamente
foi a primeira vez que eu vi o contorno
da terra tão de perto
eu percebi que olhar o mundo de cima
traz novas perspectivas
isso não é novo em um instituto chamado
overview institute que há 50 anos estuda
o impacto transformador de olhar a terra
do espaço
astronautas repetidamente relatam que
olhar a terra de longe traz a
consciência da fragilidade do planeta
problemas que antes pareciam imensos
desaparecem e surge uma vontade muito
grande de cuidar do nosso planeta
eu não fui tão longe mas eu aprendi a
olhar a minha vida e o mundo com
distanciamento é transformador olhar os
meus pensamentos os meus sentimentos e
os meus desejos condicionamento trazem o
que é essencial que o que é essencial
pode mudar dependendo da fase da vida
quando nós chegamos a nova zelândia três
anos nós não tínhamos planos de morar
ali
nós chegamos apenas para passar a
estação de furacões que é uma época onde
não se navega
mas assim que nós chegamos nos
apaixonamos pelas pessoas pelos valores
e pela natureza
nós já tínhamos mostrado em um lugar
menor e nós sabíamos que não é fácil
achar uma combinação de qualidade de
vida e de relações humanas e uma boa
estrutura de educação e trabalho
então nós resolvemos experimentar vamos
morar aqui e assim que nós tomamos a
decisão de morar na nova zelândia
meu pai teve um problema muito sério de
saúde
eu tive que vir as peças para o brasil
e naquele momento eu fiquei muito
dividida
será que a hora de voltar
faz dez anos que eu moro fora é hora de
estar perto então eu fiquei três meses
em são paulo e pela primeira vez eu
pensei não vai ser fácil criar as minhas
filhas aqui eu já vi tantas outras
formas de viver que morar numa cidade de
12 milhões de pessoas
não falava mais comigo mas eu queria
estar perto
eu preciso achar uma forma de vir com
frequência para o brasil em um mês eu
consegui um trabalho que eu podia fazer
remoto
somente da minha casa na nova zelândia e
que me trazia o brasil a cada dois meses
eu faço isso há dois anos e aquilo foi
pra mim é muito libertador porque eu
percebi que eu não precisava escolher
entre a nova zelândia ou o brasil entre
o lugar que tenha qualidade de vida ou a
minha família eu podia escolher entre a
nova zelândia eo brasil
eu acho que nós vivemos numa era hoje
das múltiplas possibilidades
a vida não precisa mais ser isso ou
aquilo
ela pode ser isso e aquilo isso abriu
muito o meu olhar para o mundo
agora nem sempre as possibilidades estão
claras para nós
muitas vezes quando eu começo uma
história eu não sei onde isso vai dar
quando eu montei a minha agência de
internet eu não sabia onde se a dar
quando fui morar a bordo
eu não sabia onde se a dar quando nos
juntamos aquele grupo de pais para falar
sobre educação e não sabia onde ia dar
e hoje entre o trabalho na nova zelândia
no brasil eu não faço a menor idéia de
onde vai dar mas de novo eu estou
vivendo um momento na vida que eu não
sei onde vai dar mas que eu confio que é
o caminho
eu fiz um trabalho esse ano na nova
zelândia ea minha cliente para agradecer
me convidou para um evento fechado numa
outra cidade chamada welinton na véspera
de viajar
eu recebi uma mensagem do nada de uma
outra pessoa dizendo você precisa para
wellington conhecer esse grupo de
empreendedores que têm tudo a ver com
você
foi nossa mas eu tô indo pra amanhã
e qual não foi a minha surpresa quando o
evento que eu fui convidado era feita
por esse grupo
pouco depois eu fui convidada a fazer
parte de uma rede de 300 empreendedores
espalhados pelo mundo que como eu tomar
uma decisão de trabalhar apenas em
projetos significativos um grupo onde
não existe hierarquia não existe chefe
o nível de colaboração é completamente
fora da curva e um grupo que em sete
anos criou mais de 20 ataques de novo eu
não sei onde vai dar mas nesse momento
eu sinto que eu preciso confiar e talvez
essa seja a coisa mais importante que eu
percebi para desenvolver um olhar que
enxerga a outras possibilidades
é preciso ter confiança e nem sempre é
fácil
e nesses momentos eu tenho uma frase que
me acompanha há muitos anos eu falei ela
hoje aqui antes de entrar nesse palco e
eu digo pra vocês
entreguem confiem aceitem e agradeço
funciona